if you thought you were the worst bad
guy in the Disney universe car you might
want to take a look at your competition
other villains wanted to overthrow their
brothers at any cost the quest for power
has turned many of these characters into
wicked beings they've harmed puppies
they've destroyed whole villages why
they've even tried to hurt babies
they've committed the most heinous
crimes and we're not letting them forget
it this list was set up to reveal the
evilest of them all did you ever wonder
which Disney bad guy is the worst we've
compared their awful deeds and rank them
into the ultimate top ten keep watching
to the end to discover which villains
made it into the top three
can you guess who they are Claude Frollo
if you're looking for Disney's most
complex villain you can call off the
surge the bad guy from the 1996 film The
Hunchback of Notre Dame is as dark and
twisted as they come when he's not
publicly humiliating poor Quasimodo
Claude Frollo is busy trying to take
down Esmeralda in the most gruesome of
ways talk about extreme behavior what
makes him so much worse is that he uses
religion as an excuse for his heinous
actions Jafar do you want to see what
happens when the desire for power goes
way too far you only have to look at a
far from the 1992 movie Aladdin trust me
my friend you'll get what's coming to
you watch can I do this Emer will stop
at nothing to push the Sultan aside
using his Cobra headed staff to
hypnotize and manipulate those who stand
in his way
and let's not even get started on his
intentions towards Jasmine gross talk
about a royal adviser with far from
regal intentions Ursula the sea witch
deliberately misleads her victims into
signing away their poor unfortunate
souls
she's like an evil warrior drying up her
calculating contracts Ursula is a slimy
double crosser but it was her sneaky
deal with Ariel in the 1989 movie the
mermaid that was her eventual undoing
she didn't get the guy or the beautiful
voice and succumb to a rather gruesome
end Gaston the villain from the 1991
movie Beauty and the Beast needs to go
to a seminar about consent Stadio marry
me
I'm very sorry Gaston but no means no
big guy narcissist Gaston is such a
toxic chauvinist that he's definitely
earned his place on this list his
attitude towards Maurice is dreamin of
the Beast
his cringy attempt at wooing Belle
seriously get a grip dude the Evil Queen
if ever there was a lesson in the
wickedness of vanity the Evil Queen is
it the villain from the 1937 movie Snow
White and the Seven Dwarfs wants to
permanently remove her stepdaughter from
the face of the earth out of sheer
jealousy and she's doing all of this
based on the opinion of a mirror
changing into an old witch and poisoning
apples shows just how far she's willing
to go to be named the fairest of them
all
Shan you the bad guy in the 1998 movie
Mulan might not get the top spot as the
most wicked villain in our list but he
does win one prize the award for most
terrifying eyes definitely goes to the
leader of the huns army he is one of the
most merciless bad guys in Disney
history taking out whole villages in his
bid to take over China his superhuman
strength and ruthless attitude earned
him a top five spot but he's
the evilest of them all Cruella De Vil
anyone who loves puppies will want to
see Cruella de Vil way up high on this
list we understand her love of fashion
but not at the cost of adorable dogs the
villain in the 1961 movie 101 Dalmatians
for her crimes on her sleeve literally
everyone in favor of animal welfare is
certainly not in favor of Cruella De Vil
she's so bad she even had a song written
about her wicked deeds so that's seven
villains accounted for who do you think
made it into our top three most evil
villains it's time to find out
scar sure most of us would love to be
the one in charge but we wouldn't betray
our family to get to the top we
certainly wouldn't throw our brother off
a cliff or plot to take down our nephew
but that kind of behavior comes easily
to scar it's not just his actions that
make the villain in the 1994 movie The
Lion King so evil it's his attitude from
engineering a wildebeest stampede to
recruiting hyenas to do his dirty work
for him he is the lowest of the low
Hades there's a correlation between bad
guys and their personal vendettas
against their brothers the villain in
the 1997 movie Hercules is also
determined to take down a sibling in his
bid to take over the world as god of the
underworld Hades doesn't have a great
track record the blue-haired bad guy
isn't above poisoning babies and
stealing Souls but there's another
magical antagonist who is the most
despicable Disney villain of them all
and that is Maleficent we've all
overreacted to being left off the guest
list right it's like someone forgot to
invite me but to see such an extreme
revenge as Maleficent is taking it to a
terrifying new level the villain of the
1959 film Sleeping Beauty was so
outraged about missing out on an invite
to Aurora's christening that she wanted
to perform the most evil deed of all and
to a baby no less
her actions are as bad as they get so
that's a wrap on Disney bad guys ring
from bad to baddest which villain do you
think is the worst of the worst and who
is your favorite let us know in the
comments make sure to subscribe to the
themes for more Disney videos like this
one thanks for watching we'll see you
next time
[Music]